okay so we are we're doing the full
origin of old man Logan which I'm not
you're pretty excited about because the
story is pretty amazing but to catch you
guys up who have not had a chance to
read old man Logan yet or who are
lagging behind or just discovered my
channel for the first time whatever the
case may be the cool thing about old man
Logan or at least about the the origin
as we're getting it here is that it
covers really like the finer points or
not really the finer points like the big
points of his life kind of the opposite
of what I just said but it covers like
the most significant moments in his life
but it's designed to sort of parallel
classic Wolverine and old man Logan next
to one another
now all this goes all the way back to a
story I'd say maybe a couple months ago
about you know old man Logan being sent
to some space station or something like
that and the idea was that the younger
version of Jean Grey had basically been
captured by a race called the brood we
don't really need to know about them but
they're able to use the powers of other
people for their own purposes and they
basically ended up forcing Jean Grey to
drive old man Logan kind of insane in
the sense that he basically started
seeing all these illusions from when he
was in the wasteland so this is saying
when he was in his other universe where
all the superheroes had been killed off
by all the supervillains now the reason
why this mattered is because at the end
of the original old man Logan story
after all man Logan it killed all the
members of the incredible whole family
and then rode off into the sunset he had
done that after taking Bruce Banner jr.
win it but we didn't know what happened
to Bruce Banner jr. we just kind of knew
that he rode off into the sunset and
that was that now we ended up figuring
out a little more I guess finding out a
little more about that with regards to
you know Jonathan Hickman is Fantastic
Four and it was the idea that Bruce
Banner jr. basically went on to become
kind of a leader of a new generation of
superheroes but old man Logan doesn't
know that instead all he knows is what
he's been forced to see by Jean Grey
which was that Bruce Banner jr.
basically became like a tyrant he became
a warlord and became another villain so
because of that the goal of old man
Logan was to travel back to the
wastelands and find a way to basically
you know save Bruce Banner jr. from
becoming a bad guy now the cool thing
about this is that writer Jeff Lemire
offers a sort of meta commentary on how
different writers use time travel
because it's no secret that there are
some writers out there that use time
travel as an escape they basically write
a story they back themselves into a
corner they don't know how to end it so
they're just like well time travel and
then everything gets fixed the funny
thing about this is Lemire uses that but
the way that he sort of comments on it
is that old man Logan begins going
around to
all these different members of the
Marvel superhero community that have the
ability to manipulate time so like
Scarlet Witch Doctor Strange some of
those individuals who are
technologically advanced and they all
basically say no we're not going to give
you the ability to go back in time time
is not something you can just kind of
mess around with forever you'll
eventually screw things up and so
eventually he tracks down and locates an
old villain of his named Osmo Diaz now
as Marius is not really relevant here I
mean he's relevant insofar that he has
like its own little story where we can
cover that at the end what we do know is
that automotives is the guy who dabbled
in like sorcery and different things
like that and so he basically gives old
man Logan an amulet and says as long as
you hold this amulet you will be able to
go back to the wasteland and figure out
what's going on but if you let it go you
could potentially be stuck there now of
course I've know Diaz doing this had its
own nefarious purposes and again we'll
find out what that is but essentially
what happened is that instead of the
physical body of old man Logan being
whisked into the past
what is up happening is like his mind or
soul whatever you want to call his
essence up basically gets attached to
the amulet and it begins jumping from
body to body and that's why over the
course of this story we're going to see
his physical appearance change because
instead of his body physically being
transformed it's only his mind and so
his mind will jump from one point in his
life to another and that error will
reflect one portal you know what point
in time he's in so a really good example
of this is where we initially pick up
with the war of 1812 now the funny thing
about this is that Jeff Lemire really
kind of says that like classic will rain
like The Wolverine you think up we got
his adamantium ripped out and just like
loves killing stuff you know classic
Wolverine in old man Logan
are similar but they're different and
the reason why I say that is because
classic Wolverine was born shortly
before 1900 he was born like eighteen
between 1870 something in 1890 something
I don't remember off the top of my head
uh but there's no way he could have
fought in the war of 1812 old man Logan
did and what this tells us is that old
man Logan has a hundred years or so on
the classic war brain now the reason why
this is all so cool is because it also
answers questions about like his healing
factor because one of the big questions
people always had one of the questions I
always saw in the comments is if
Wolverine has a healing factor how does
he get old but we answered that question
before when we talked about like the
nature of healing factors and adamantium
of different things like that and we
likened it to the idea of you hitting a
tree stump right like in that video I
said okay let's say that we give you
like a plastic hammer and it only weighs
a couple of ounces and I
okay I want you to start hitting this
tree stump with this plastic hammer
you'll be able to probably hit it for
like hours and hours and hours but if I
take away that plastic hammer and I give
you a 50 pound hammer you won't be able
to hit it for nearly as long that
metaphor applies to all brain in the
sense that you hitting a tree stump with
a plastic hammer is Wolverines healing
factor without adamantium adamantium is
not poisoning his body all he has to do
is just recover from whatever injury he
happens to sustain and basically stem
the flow of his own energy process but
when adamantium was introduced to his
body now his body had to not only fight
off adamantium it also had to fight off
whatever damage he sustained and
whatever conflict he happened to be in
which is the equivalent of me giving you
a 50 pound hammer and asking you to hit
a tree stump and so what this says is
that in addition to him gaining is out
of mantium later on down the line which
we'll see as well as how old he is it
offers some measure of an explanation on
why he's old now again it's not perfect
and it's not designed to be I mean it's
not like Jeff Lemire sits down and says
okay guys here's a step-by-step answer
on why old man Logan is old we just
gotta have to take it for what it is and
just sort of go with it but following
this I mean it's really kind of a
straightforward set of events but he
escapes and he attacks the soldiers and
then you know just let some of them live
because he feels bad for him and that's
really about it he grabs the amulet and
his mind is whisked out of his body and
it's raced off and it's actually sent
forward in time to the point where he
basically ends up becoming a part of the
Weapon X project now that's the reason
why I like this story is because it
gives us these finer moments but it
allows us to sort of explain these
different scenarios that take place
around case in point
weapon acts for really for something
like 40 years what the next was just
this clandestine organization that gave
Wolverine is adamantium and that's all
we knew like it was just something that
Chris Claremont you know right at Chris
Claremont introduced to kind of expand
on this doctor story of war right a
little bit and that's all we had we just
knew with some company or the result of
a joint venture between the United
States CIA and Canada's super
clandestine organization Department K
and that was it I mean it was the
craziest thing it wasn't until you know
really in the late 1990s going into the
early 2000s that we got these
connections and what Marvel ended up
saying is that like Captain America was
weapon one there was this overarching
program called weapons Plus and the idea
was to basically stem the rise of the
mutant population or something along
those lines
the origins behind weapons Plus have
changed over the years like it's been
you know while some guy named John
Sablan wanted to eliminate mutants
because he couldn't control them and
then it was you know some villain named
Romulus you know that basically
engineered all the events of Wolverines
life there have been different origins
behind weapons plots and so on and so
forth but the common theme at least
nowadays anyway is that there is weapon
plus and then under weapons plus you had
weapon one which was Captain America
Steve Rogers the problem with this was
that what dr. Abraham Erskine injected
Steve Rogers with the Super Soldier
Serum he died before he could tell
anybody what the what the formula was
and so Captain America was the only
successful super soldier and so you know
weapons punch is basically forced to
move on to weapons two three four five
six seven eight and nine which
eventually you know had like Santa nets
and all these different characters and
and then it gave us Weapon X which is
weapon ten and that's will range so
again it's really kind of a cool little
bit of a little bit of history there
when it comes to this idea but his
exposure here in Weapon X is two pages
long it's not lengthy by any standard of
measurement and it doesn't have to be
because it's such an intrinsic part of
Wolverines history most anybody who's
ever heard of Wolverine knows what
Weapon X is in some form or fashion even
if only it's just because of what they
seen in the movies and so because of
that the amulet really just kind of
whisks him away and that's really the
end of that and so what it does is it
actually land him in a direct conflict
between the Incredible Hulk and Wendigo
now when they go we don't need to worry
about it that's a whole kind of
ridiculous concept in Marvel but this is
actually the second or third time that
old man Logan and The Incredible Hulk
had fought one another now again the
cool thing about this is a little bit of
the history behind it when Wolverine
first will heal was first introduced to
the Weapon X project he gained his
adamantium of course as we know he kind
of you know what crazy basically managed
to engineers escaped and then he just
stumbled off into the woods eventually
he was discovered by James Hudson I
think his name was who basically became
Vindicator who was part or I guess
leader of a group called Alpha Flight
and alpha flight was part of a group
where really as part of Canada's
department H and department age was
different from Department K in the sense
of the Department K was like the CIA
department age was basically an
organization that was part of Canada's
government that served the purpose of
monitoring and dealing with superhuman
threats and so you know Department age
would just kind of sit around and it
would look at things that it would say
Oh
The Incredible Hulk has stumbled into
you know the into Canada we have to deal
with and so that's why wool rain and The
Incredible Hulk fought for the
first time because following his
encounter with James Hudson he was
basically brought back to department age
he received a ton of psychotherapy in
order that you know trying to bring him
as close as they could to being a normal
human being and then he just started
carrying all these all these different
strike force missions and so because of
the fact that fighting the Incredible
Hulk was basically suicide for anybody
who didn't have a superpower
Wolverine took up the mantle and then
faced off against the Incredible Hulk
for the first time so that's where all
that kind of comes into play but the
fact remains here that with him facing
off against the Incredible Hulk it's
actually kind of cool you know just
because of the fact that it's the
Incredible Hulk and it's when to go when
to go of course face off against
Wolverine on a multitude of occasions
which is why he's included here and he's
basically kind of akin to like a
werewolf in the sense that if you're bit
by a Wendigo you will become one that's
really it I mean Wendigo is an actual
character and he does have his own
history he's just not really important
by any standard of measurement so
because of that is a little bit of a
familiarity here and this is the
Incredible Hulk recognizes Wolverine is
like hey look if you're fighting when to
go and I'm fighting when to go then
we're friends only for Wolverine to turn
on the Incredible Hulk and The
Incredible Hulk actually gets ready to
smash his head with a rock and then of
course you know Wolverine grabs his
amulet and he's basically whisked away
in transition back to I guess transition
to the future which picks up with the
Phoenix saga and again this is really
cool because it's just these small
little snippets throughout the history
of its characters publications so with
the x-men Dark Phoenix movie coming out
in the casting calls and casting
announcements and stuff more or less
take well I guess the casting calls are
over but the casting announcements
taking place we could probably offer a
little more explanation on the Phoenix
saga than we normally would but a
Phoenix saga was really cool because it
was basically this idea that with the
x-men you know originally written by
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby it lasted for
some 60 issues before they basically
realized that nobody cared so what they
ended up doing is they basically stopped
creating news stories with like issue
number 64 66 or something along those
lines before about the next 30 issues or
so it was just reprints so going from
issue 60 something to issue 90 something
it was just reprints of stories that had
already been told and the whole reason
behind this was because Marvel wanted to
relaunch it somewhere along the line and
they wanted to keep the story fresh in
the minds of readers and so what they
ended up doing is underlain wine they
launched giant-size x-men number one and
what I did is basically said that the
original x-men team of Cyclops and Jean
Grey and Iceman and Angel and those guys
I had basically just been kidnapped and
Xavier had to form a new x-men team to
go through and to to rescue them now
that was where Wolverine was originally
introduced to the x1 was with this you
know giant sides I spent number one when
he was brought in as the second you know
x-men team but eventually when Chris
Claremont took over his rider he looked
around at the landscape of the x-men at
the time and essentially said that Jean
Grey was his character who was
consistently wasted and she really was
you know back in the old x-men stories
under you know Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
she was just like the weakest character
like during training sessions she would
get overwhelmed she always had to be
rescued by Cyclops and to a degree it
introduced this love relationship
between the two of them in a sense that
he was her rescuer but it was very much
entrenched in this old-school method of
thinking that you know the damsel in
distress was a was a necessity when it
came to comics and so Claremont
basically wiped all that Elaine and said
let's reinvigorate Jean Grey and he
introduced the Phoenix force and made
her one of the strongest beings in
evidence ever really existed in the
history of Marvel Comics and fans loved
it fans were over the moon for Jean Grey
and they were so pissed when she died
they were so mad I remember that people
they got so pissed it was one of the
craziest things to ever see like people
were just screaming it was something to
the whole but the fact remains when Jean
Grey first arrived on the scene it was
really this essence that the Phoenix
force was just kind of overwhelmed with
the idea of like love and hate and anger
and wrath and so on and so forth and
that eventually led to the gr2 the
Phoenix force kind of having a psychotic
break and then going into the Dark
Phoenix saga but at the time that this
takes place this follows between the
Phoenix and the Dark Phoenix saga more
or less at least it seems to be the case
but it's basically Jean Grey being a bad
guy and the reason why this matters is
because as we know there was a very
strong love triangle between you know
Jean Grey Cyclops and Wolverine of
course January wasn't Cyclops
but Wolverines always had an interest in
her and there were a few times over the
course of Marvel's Marvel Comics when he
was basically shown that Jean Grey did
love Wolverine and she actually wanted
to be with him but her loyalty was to
Cyclops which is the reason why that
never really happened but what does does
is this really kind of forces us to face
the idea of when Jean Grey basically
became a villain and when she
essentially took off and that was really
about it now this follows up to the idea
of Jean Grey eventual death which old
man Logan the Wolverine doesn't really
hang around for and he basically just
bails off from here we actually end up
jumping to Japan with a character named
Mariko now of all the different love
interests that have existed and more
comics for Wolverine Marika is probably
one of the most important and the reason
why is because she first appeared an
uncanny x-men number 118 and 1979 and
she was the first real attempt by writer
Chris Claremont to flesh out the
backstory of Wolverine but keep in mind
when it came to like revealing the
history of will rain it was like you
know a little small thing here and like
a little small thing there you know it
was never fully fleshed out because one
of the most intriguing aspects of will
rain was the mystique in the mystery
that surrounded him in terms of who he
was and where he came from that was also
another huge part of his story in the
sunset where Weapon X basically screwed
with his memories it was will be uncover
something new that we didn't know before
and so basically offered writer Chris
Claremont an endless possibility when it
came to like all the different aspects
of his origin that he could craft out
that he could flesh out different things
like that so of course uh one of the
things that's shown here is that he's
actually facing off against the hand
that's not super important it's not like
it's a pivotal moment in his life it's
just one of those things where Wolverine
had come across a lot of different
groups over the course of his life and
faced off against a lot of different a
lot of different organizations one of
which was the hint the fact remains that
Marika was a character who again was
designed to flesh things out a little
bit and she was actually a really a
woman who was the daughter of I cannot
remember that guy's name for the life of
me but she was the daughter of the guy
who was in charge of a group called the
clan Yashida I think it was and it was
just one of these different
organizations that existed in Japan that
was involved in the realm of like you
know crime and different things like
that like a Yakuza and so on and so
forth eventually Wolverine killed her
dad and this kind of created a I guess
of engagement of sorts for the two of
them became more romantically involved
in they were before but eventually she
actually ended up dying and so what were
a kind of had to leave her behind but
the reason why this was cool is because
it's a chance for him to go back and see
her again so again it really just kind
of highlights these small little moments
that riders have introduced over the
course of his publication history with
regards to like significant moments so
for here we actually end up having I
mean of course grab his amulet and he's
basically whisked away to majeure board
now magic ore is a really really cool
aspect in the realm of Marvel Comics and
the reason why is because it's kind of
like this Wild West of the criminal
world now there is like a law to a
degree it's not like you're like just
like rides around like the Wild West
just shoots everything up so maybe
calling it the Wild West isn't the best
choice of words but the fact remains
that it is basically the idea that in
magic or almost
anything goes now the reason why old man
Logan is here while brains here is
because of the fact that there was a
point in time after the events of you
know Mariko and after the events of the
permit age and weapon acts and
Department K and all that kind of good
stuff he eventually took up residence in
major port and he basically became this
sort of assassin for hire he was a
soldier of fortune he would basically
loan his skills out to the highest
bidder and in turn he would go through
and just kill whoever it was they wanted
to have killed now if there's a little
more to it than that in terms of people
who were sort of manipulating him and
the fact that he had a handler and
eventually turned against them and all
that kind of good stuff but this was a
point in his life when he was just an
assassin that's really all he was and
that's why I'm a jerk or has always been
such an important part of the Wolverine
legacy because he's always gone back
there's always been instances where he's
revisited matter for us it's not very
often that you see a place in Marvel
Comics where it's like here's one place
it like superheroes and like superhero
teams just will not go - you don't
really see it that often magic wars
really like the only place where you
find that kind of thing so it's always
one of these cool scenarios in this
instance he had previously just kind of
pissed off some kind of rival gang they
ended up attacking him and of course he
basically kills them all that's really
about it and then we jump to his time at
the Xavier mansion now this is where
Jeff Lemire invokes something really
cool because something that I hope you
guys have noticed so far is that this
origin with the exception of you know
when he was born this origin story of
old man Logan and Wolverine are almost
identical they're almost the exact same
what this does is it basically has Jeff
Lemire coming back erasing pretty much
all the origin stuff that we've seen
with regards to the whole you know set
of events with classic Wolverine or at
least it seems that way and essentially
saying that this is classic war brain
everything we've seen up to this point
is classic well brain the brain that how
does that enantiomer ripped out the
Wolverine that joined the x-men at the
request of Charles Xavier they're all
basically the same the difference is the
night that superheroes died and we know
that with more comics right like we know
that everything is in a singular
timeline until like something huge
happens and when that huge thing happens
that future becomes an alternate future
if it's changed so with you know the
night the superheroes died that future
became an alternate reality and that
alternate reality could have gone to
distinctly different ways one way is
that it continues along the main Marvel
timeline where the old man Logan future
never happened the other reality is that
it's where the old man Logan future did
happen and the reason why that
is because what old man Logan does is he
actually tells Iceman I'm going to be
kidnapped by a guy named Osmo Diaz he's
going to basically send my mind
spiraling throughout all space and time
you have to find him and you have to
stop him the whole explanation about
time is the only way that I can make
this make sense it's the only way that I
can really consolidate these two things
otherwise there's no other scenario
where this makes any sense whatsoever
and so again that seems to be what's
going on here that at this point right
here when old man Logan is telling
Iceman about the schemes of Osmo Deus
that the future of the super villains
taking over the world has not happened
yet which means that Iceman has the
knowledge of old man Logan being
kidnapped by Asmodeus and two different
realities he has the knowledge of this
happening in the reality when he
presumably dies when the superheroes are
a supervillains take over the world but
he also has this knowledge in the main
Marvel Universe where things continue on
as if the old man Logan future never
happened and so the reason why this
matters is because what it does is well
you know old man Logan's line basically
transitions to his future self in the
wasteland where he runs back into his
own family
Iceman continues on as if the old man
Logan future never happened all the
while having the knowledge that Osmo
Deus is holding old man Logan hostage
and so early on captive in some building
somewhere some Shack I don't know slum
was like anyway the coolest thing about
this is that this deals with the idea of
old man Logan basically returning home
back to his family because River and the
old man Logan been story his family was
killed by the by the banner painted by
the Hulk family they literally
slaughtered his son and his daughter his
wife and the whole nine yards and so
this really begs an interesting question
it begs a really cool scenario because
reading this you know we would be like
well I mean know like at some point he
would have to go back like why would he
want to live this life out but it makes
sense because if you were suddenly
yanked away from a point in your life
that you absolutely adored and you were
given the opportunity to go back
wouldn't you take it you know it's like
for example Star Trek generations I
don't how many of you guys saw Star Trek
generations but there was the whole idea
of the ribbon the movie itself was not
the best but the concept of the ribbon
was cool and people who got stuck inside
the ribbon we're basically transported
to this you know ethereal alternate
dimension where all they did is just
continue to relive the greatest moments
in their lives and there's this really
cool discussion between Captain Picard
Patrick Stewart there we go that guy's
name escaped me for a second there's
this really cool conversation between
Patrick's do it with the Goldberg where
we go over talks about being pulled away
doesn't say I was saved I was rescued
she says I was yanked I was torn away
because they didn't want to leave and
that's the coolest thing about this is
it draws on that idea
I mean imagine the greatest moment
you've ever experienced in your life and
then imagine you could spend an eternity
there why would you want to go why would
you want anybody to save you and your
mind they're not saving you they're
literally yanking you away from the
thing you love and care about so much
and so initially old man Logan just kind
of abandoned this life he basically you
know walks away from the whole idea of
going back and being a superhero in the
main Marvel Universe he's just like I'm
back home my family's safe and the idea
is that he can basically save his
family's life because remember in the
old man Logan's story The Hulk family
killed old man Logan's family while he
was on a mission with Hawkeye but if
Hawkeye comes knocking on his door and
says hey look I need you to come on a
mission with me knowing what he knows
now he can say no he can be there when
the whole family shows up trying to kill
his family slaughter the whole family
and keep his family alive and so that's
the coolest thing about all this is
because it presents a litany of
possibilities but the other half of this
is everything that I'm odious is doing
back in the main Marvel Universe and
what we end up finding out is that we're
you know the mind of one man Logan had
been removed from his body and
transported throughout all space and
time
Osmo Diaz is trying to auction him off
our motives calls together like Hydra
and the hand and like advanced idea
mechanics and all these criminal
organizations and basically says look I
will cast a spell on him he'll just be a
vessel more or less you just kind of be
like an empty shell he'll do whatever it
is that you tell him to do he'll be an
assassin he'll carry out all different
kinds of missions it's Wolverine he's
got a healing factor he's a little older
than we would normally expect but he's
got a healing factor he's literally the
perfect assassin but in the midst of all
this because of the fact that old man
Logan had told Iceman about the fact of
were even kidnapped and who was holding
him Iceman eventually shows up and
rescues him and so what does does is it
basically forces his mind back into his
body he's eventually just kind of you
know required to say goodbye to his
family in the old man Logan wasteland
but the reason why that's cool is
because of the fact that it's a chance
for him to basically say goodbye memory
he didn't get that during the original
oh man Logan story he just came home and
found his family slaughtered and then he
unleashed holy hell on the banner family
dude it was what man it was one of the
coolest thing there was one of the
coolest moments in that story ever
because it's just like like I don't know
read
old man Logan and like you turn the page
the other guy like takes off his hat
he's like oh man like dude I'm sorry to
tell you man like they came while you
were gone and like oh man Logan opens
the door and his family slaughtered I
was like aw man it's on now son and like
he pops his claws and I was like her man
like some folks are gonna die man like
holy hell it was a wrath of God man like
there was some church going on it was
Simmons's bananas he was one of the
coolest things that I've ever seen but
again this is the way you just kind of
ride out the character is basically a
swan song it's a chance to basically say
look I broke this great big huge
grandiose epic you know even though it's
only about 20 20 20 comments or so it's
just this epic story with the character
of old man Logan and it's basically
saying goodbye to his past you know
because that's what he does you know
once you've saved my Iceman once his
mind is restored to his body
you know alongside Jean Grey and the
rest of the other superheroes who
basically says look you know it was a
chance for me to say goodbye to the
family that I had maybe that's what I
needed was to just say look it's been
real and it's been good and so it's time
for me to walk away it's time for me to
live in the present right now as opposed
to focusing on the past and so what this
does is it puts him in a position to
where Marvel can basically move forward
with the character of old man Logan the
real question to ask is will he be as
good now that he's not focusing on this
past that's the real question that we
have to ask you but if you guys are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the report if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later please
[Music]